hi there this um film I'd like to talk
about
telepathy
I think everybody's heard about
telepathy but may not be bothered with
it or you could be interested in
telepathy
they say that um we all have it we all
have our Deja Vu moments and um
perhaps in life you've thought wow how
come I always think of that exactly the
same time as they were thinking of it
I get it very strongly with my partner
Jane and um
we almost know what each other's
thinking
and then I'll come out with something
completely out of the blue
and just say I don't believe it I was
thinking of exactly the same thing a
moment ago
so
if you've had the experience what if
you're a human being I'm sure you have
then
I think this may be for seniors rather
than queue grades but who knows I was
happy developing it
acute grade and I was very interested
all the way from fifth Cube
and um over the years
like to look at it and delve in deeper
coach
he he liked to study power the mind and
in his um
key in daily life
book he shows some exercises and this is
all about what you're having to do with
your mind even though he would show what
the body is doing
um standing on one leg holding a fist
out while people push it
it's the mind that's going having to
make some form of mass
and staple it and make the body become
stable in what I consider
justifying angles
so
he he could show you how to defy angles
and this was the power of his mind
um Hitler used to do it by using voice
tones
and um but so there's lots of things you
can do with mine I want to talk about
telepathy at the moment so if you want
to let's say you're doing a swords or
Ken or Joe work this is a really good
time to start doing it if you know that
peace is set pieces really well
what you can do is
when you're standing in front of them
you're you may show yourself twitching
thinking that they're about to attack
you and they don't move and then you
feel an idiot because you thought they
were going to move and they didn't
or you can be calm inside and try to
just send out like a a what radio wave
like this
but don't send out too strong because
what you're really doing is even though
you're sending out like this you're
actually receiving it
so what you need to do is you need to
ask yourself what am I receiving
it and I get a voice in my head and it
might just say one cent one word it
might just say calm
so that means that it's telling me not
for me to be calm but they're calm they
might be playing a game a trick on me
and wanting
to them for me not to know when they're
going to swing with the Ken or thrust
with the Joe they want it to be a
surprise so they're switched off of
omitting any ways that I can pick up
so when doing that
often teachers will tell you look at
look at the sort of the chest area here
don't look into their eyes look at that
chest area
but
you're not hearing your ears you're
hearing with your
internal telepathic mind
you might go blank you might find that
you're getting a lot of confusion a lot
of you know what I call electric
interference going in making you think
you're hearing things
that you're perhaps not
but
just try it I now fortunate enough that
if I partner somebody
they automatically think because I'm the
senior person they're the underdog and
yeah I'm trying to be their puppet I'm
trying to read them
and so when they
when they're about to cut I already know
that they're going to cut
I know that the weather there
mind is in their upper body or whether
they're going to attack me as a whole
whether they're going to attack me as an
instant where really they're not in
charge of their own swing around can cut
there's lots of variations
so please when you get time
try to test yourself out and do it over
a period of years not uh not weeks but
you'll find that once you start to trust
in yourself and you start to rely on
listening to yourself
more
the better your receptors
will become
and you could start then perhaps with
anything like coach utero said Keen
daily life in other words your spirit
allow your spirit to guide you more so
when you make decisions in life in
general life you make better decisions
because you're listening to what your
subconscious is telling you rather than
what you're
um
flattering conscious he's trying to
decide
and I say this for all problems in life
all decisions in life
we get in the way our ego our conscious
gets in the way our quick decisions and
then afterwards regretting those quick
decisions
so
you can ask a question with your mind
if you get a no but you personally want
to do it you'll override that
and then perhaps later you'll go I
should have listened to my conscience
subconscious not conscious
okay well thank you for listening and I
use it you've got to start somewhere
so why not start with um partner Ken
partner practice
where it's not too busy and you can
learn how stable you can keep how calm
you can keep your mind then open your
receptors and each time you partner do
this each time you are the attacker see
if you can calm your mind and cut as one
being rather than now
if you say nail and you cut like this
you're cutting your arms your hands your
upper body is like you're throwing out
only half power half-heartedness
and the person receiving it will receive
it with ease there will be no will
solid Mass power behind the attack once
solid mass starts to come become from
the person
then you have to match it with mass
therefore you can match it with either
calmness
or if you match it with determination
then really
you're matching it with power speed and
ignorance you're not matching it with
blending softness Harmony calmness
okay if you need to know more on this
please contact me and we can have more
discussions about this but telepathy is
something that we need and that will
lead you on to a much greater
understanding of mind power in years to
come if you find that of Interest
some people find collecting
butterflies beetles
some people like flying some people like
playing golf you know we all have our
our hobbies and our likes and dislikes
but to to reach higher levels in Aikido
we do need to understand the telepathic
mind the inner mind the subconscious
mind
we must separate it from the ego mind
the conscious mind the irrational mind
thank you for your time